the war in Syria made Abdullah Ayyoub
and his family refugees in their country
he also lost his son it's been four
years since Abdul Rahman disappeared
while traveling to neighboring Lebanon
his taxi driver told the family he was
taken at a government checkpoint please
help me tell me where he is I just want
to hear his voice I don't know anything
about him I just want to know if he's
alive or dead there are many others in a
similar position human rights groups
have documented the detention abduction
and enforced disappearance of at least
130 thousand Syrians most had taken part
in peaceful protests when the uprising
began in 2011 calls by the UN and other
organizations for their release from
government jails have grown louder with
the spread of coronavirus in late March
Syrian President Bashar Assad issued an
amnesty for some crimes without
mentioning political prisoners rights
groups say the decree was a tactic to
avoid international pressure they have
documented the release of less than 100
people jailed for common crimes while
more than 100 were arrested in the same
period other merciful hamantash mahalia
it was the 18th amnesty issued and still
130,000 political prisoners are in jails
there have also been deaths due to
torture despite the amnesties the Assad
government denies holding prisoners of
conscience and torturing detainees to
death in secret security prisons but you
and investigators say tens of thousands
of people have disappeared and may no
longer be alive some who survived like
dr. mohamed abu Hallel are turning to an
ally of Bashar al-assad for help he
wrote a letter to Russian President
Vladimir Putin which was published in
the Russian media I urged him to
pressure Bashar Assad to release the
arbitrary detain people the most
vulnerable so far my email is empty they
didn't provide me any response so far
but at least I did my duty actually to
hold him accountable actually years of
campaigning have done little to pressure
the government to release the prisoners
or allow independent monitors into
detention centers if you believe
anything will change for Abdul Rahman's
mother there doesn't seem to be any end
to her pain said Hoda al Jazeera Beirut